[Musique]
il
comme les diamants cette musique de film
et éternelle le thème de james bond est
aussi célèbre que son agent le thème
qu'on reconnaît le plus de james bond
c'est le thème de l'agent 007
c'est ce qu'on entend avec la guitare
avec l' orchestre avec des cuivres c'est
ce qui donne la signature de jenny sport
c'est ce qu'on appelle un leit motiv le
leitmotiv c'est un thème qui est associé
un personnage ou un double aussi à temps
pour la sortie au grand écran de la
25ème aventures de james bond mourir
peut attendre
l'orchestré symphonique de québec
présente un concert autour de l'univers
musical de l'agent 007 la musique de
james bond ces différents thèmes c'était
pic c'est dramatique a lancé des grands
thèmes qui se marie très bien avec leur
compagnie
[Musique]
chaque film de la franchise propose une
chanson qui a le potentiel de devenir
aussi populaire que le long métrage
depuis le début il ya toujours une
affiliation entre un artiste populaire
très connue très en vogue qui représente
son époque et les films de james bond
moi
oh so it's in
c'est un exercice technique difficile
de chanter la petit bois 12 le lien
tissé nature ou de chine et estime
entre autres et puis après de chanter
les grosses thoune 2 qui demande
beaucoup plus de voix puis beaucoup plus
de puissance vocale
[Musique]
visiteurs
mais aucune chanteuse qui revenu à
plusieurs reprises sur les basses et qui
est l'art chanteuse la chanteuse de
goldfinger qui est une grande chanteuse
à voix qui dont la voix surplombe
d'absolument des les orchestres
majestueux très bas c'est une signature
importante
sonorités l'on entend de tout cuivre des
grands corps de migrants vois ça l'a
marqué l'histoire des james bond jusqu'à
jusqu'à adel
[Musique]
souvent le caractère qui est associé à
l'artiste choisit vient aussi dans le
même sens que ce qu'on veut donner comme
personnalité au james bond ici tanya
beaumont radio canada québec
[Musique]